ونحييكم الى الملف الثالث استيقظت احيائهم
في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم على اصوات
انفجارات قويه اثرى تجدد القتال مباشره
بين قوات الجيش وعناصر الدعم السريع عقب
انتهاء الهدنه قصيرا امتدت ليوم واحد فقط
ونقلت وكاله انباء عن شهود عيان ان
اشتباكات وقعت بين الطرفين فورا تاء
الهدنه في انحاء متفارقه غرب وجنوب مدينه
الخرطوم وفي مدينه بحري استخدم خلالها
واستخدم الجيش الطيران الحربي بينما ردت
قوه الدعم السريع باستخدام المضادات
الارضيه بكثافه وتسببت هذه الاشتباكات
بمقتل شخصين من اسره واحده ودمر جزءا من
المبنى الذي يسكنه وفي مدينه الاوبيض
بولايه شمال كردفان لا تزال قوه دعم
السريع تفرز حصارا على المدينه في محاوله
لسيطره عليها ويشتكي الاهالي من ان مستشفى
المدينه يواجه خطرا اغلاق وشبح الجوع
وان شبح الجوع يهدد سكنا المدينه من جهتها
اعلنت اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر ان
فرق الحمايه لها تستقبل اتصالات دائما
للابلاغ عن حالات فقدان واختفاء لافراد من
العائلات السودانيه وان عمليه البحث عن
المفقودين المبلغ عنهم مستمره لكنها تواجه
الكثير من العقبات بسبب استمرار القتاده
اشتباكات بعد الهدنه الهدنه الكهنه 24
ساعه عادت بصوره قويه جدا
وسودان او الشعب السوداني يعني يعاني من
الحته دي معانه كبيره جدا
وبالذات في النهب والسلب اكثر من الضرب
لابد من الناس شنو تلجا لمشهودنا قصيره
فقط تكون خذنا طويله وبعدها يكون في سلام
دائم ان شاء الله ما فينا كده انه الحرب
لانه المواطن معها قبل كذا والله بالنسبه
للهدنه الهدنه يعني كانت زي يعني كويسه ما
بطاله لكن هي ما بتفيد بشيء يعني بالنسبه
للمواطن يعني صراحه تعبت تعب شديد في
الهدنه دي وما قدر يعني يعمل اي شيء في
خلال الهدنه دي حتى الهودنات السابقه
الهدنه دي انا ما بتعمل حاجه غير تخلي
الدعم السريع هو يعني يبقى يجمع صفوفه
حاجات زي دي كده
نناقش هذا الموضوع واسمعنا الى اراء
الشارع السوداني في الواقع سنحاول نقل هذه
المعاناه لضيوفنا من لندن طيبه الزينه
صحفي السوداني ارحب بكم من الرياض فتحه
الرحمن يوسف الصحفي السوداني اهلا بكم
ضيوفي الكرام سابدا معك سيد فتحي الرحمن
استمعت لبعض السودانيين في الواقع
والاصوات كثيره والتعليقات كثيره ونقراها
كل يوم تقريبا لم تعد هناك ثقه فيما يسمى
هدنه لانه منذ اول اعلان هدنه تم اختراقها
وتم خرقها تواصل الاقتتال بدانا ننشرح
نفرح قليلا نتامل خيرا في محادثات مباشره
انسحب منها الجيش ثم بعد هناك حديث عن
امكانيات عوده او عوده هدنه اخرى ولكن شعب
سوداني يقول فقد نسيق في كل هذا من يتحمل
مسؤوليه مالت اليه الامور من عدم ثقه في
كل الاطراف في داخل السود اني استاذ فتح
الرحمن
طيب السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
تحيات من لندن والتحيه للمشاهدين الاعزاء
يعني للاسف الشديد نحن نتحدث عن مواقع
مرير وواقع صنعته قوات الدعم السريع يعني
لا تستمعين الى يعني
تعليقات بعض المواطنين ان الهده لا تفي
باغراضهم بل هي تجمع صفوفها قوات الدعم
السريعه لمزيد من النحو والمزيد من السرقه
ومزيد من الارهاب وهي تختلط وليس فقط
الجيش لا يجامع صفوفه
الاشجار في مكانه في مقاره في قياده
العامه في مركز عملياته في القوات المناطق
المناطق المعنيه منطقه
المدرعات منطقه الدفاع الجوي قوات الدعم
السريع هي جاءت بعشرين
عشرين الف مقاتل ثم جهزت نفسها
طيب ما رايك في
زياده تقوم بهذا الدور الان وتستغلها قوه
الدعم السريع لاعاده التمركز بينما الجيش
ويحافظ على مقراته ويتابع ما يحدث
طبعا هذا غير صحيح كلام فيه قدر من
الادعاء قوات الدعم السريع منذ البدايه
يعني وقلنا الكلام هذا في مشاركات عديده
ان هي مع السلام ومع وقف دائم لاطلاق
النار والدخول في مفاوضات جاده تقود الى
التفكيك الانقلاب واعاده المسار
الديمقراطي وتمكين الشعب السوداني من
تقرير مصيري في ارادته الحره
ولكن السؤال المطروح في خصوص من يتحمل
مسؤوليه عدم
نجاح هذه الهدن من يتحملها سيد الطيب طبعا
هم الانقلابيين باعتبار انهم ليست لديهم
فرص للحياه في ظل نظام مدني ديمقراطي
ولذلك يراهنون على الفوضى وعلى الحرب
باعتبار
تتحدث عن من تتحدث عن الدعم السريع الذي
بات الان الجيش يقول عنه متمردين
وانقلابيين ام تتحدث عن كتل داخل الجيش
الذي يقول كذلك الدعم السريع بانهم في
النهايه هم انقلابيون ويريدون مسح المسار
المدني
الواقع في السودان
يؤكد ان البرهان ومن خلفه فلول النظام
السابق قاموا بانقلاب في 25 اكتوبر 2021
هذا الانقلاب كان على حكومه الثوره غير
عبد الله حمدو وكان هناك وثيقه دستوريه
حاكم للفتره الانتقاليه البرهان قيم هذه
الحكومه بجرد قلم وعلق
[موسيقى]
الوثيقه الدستوريه او لغه الوثيقه
الدستوريه
والقى وجود لجنه ازاله
ازاله التمكين اللي كانت معنيه في تحقيق
اهداف الثوره ويبدا هذه المرحله واضحه في
الواقع نحن ناقشناها وكنت حضرتك معنا
السيد طيب الزين تتذكر
ولكن اود ان اتحدث عن المستقبل صحيح هو
الاساس ناقشناه ولكن الخلافات لازلت قائمه
لها سبب يطرح سؤال ما المستقبل سيد فتح
الرحمن ما المنتظر من هذه الهدن حتى وان
لم تحترم ولكن هل نزل الوقت سانح للجلوس
على الطاوله لايجاد او الالتزام بحل سياسي
طيب شكرا جزيلا لو سمحت بس ادعيني ارد
قليلا على الاخ الطيب يعني هو
الذي يسالك عن اسمك يقول لكم ما اسمك ثم
تقول له اسمه ثم يقول لك لا ليس هذا اسمك
ليست اسمه يعني هو
يتنكر اسمك يعني حتى يعني هو يقلب يقلب
الحقائق بشكل معهد يعني يتحدث عن انه قوات
الدعم السريع هي التي ستعطي بالحريه
والديمقراطيه وبالحكومه الحكومه الحكومه
المدنيه
بالحكم الديمقراطي يا اخي يا اخي يا اخي
انتم تلعبون على الشعب السوداني الابيه
المعلم الذي علم العالم يا اخي كيف يصنع
الديمقراطيه يا اخي يا اخي هذا كلام فيه
كثير من التجمع على الشعب السوداني
جيش السوداني ارجع الى حديثك
اسمح لي الوقت انتهى السيد طيب تعليقك
باختصار
تعليقي هو ان لا خيار للشعب السوداني ولا
مخرج من هذه الازمه الا بتفكيك الانقلاب
انقلاب 25
25 21
واعاده المسار الديمقراطي والاستعانه
دكتور عبد الله حمدوك الذي قاد المرحله
الانتقاليه بنجاح وكل الخيرين والبناء
مستقبل مشرق للسودان لكن اي كلام اخر هو
مجرد نفاق ودجل
وضحت الصوره والاكيد باننا سنبقى في
متابعه لكل ذلك من لندن طيبه زينه صحفي
السوداني ومن الرياض عبد الرحمن او فاتحه
الرحمن يوسف وصحفي السوطين شكرا لكم
السلام عليكم